hello and welcome to the 27th PHP
tutorial this tutorial we will be
discussing working with a database
depending on who you're hosting is
setting it up is pretty much the same
usually you'll just go to hosting then
like databases at a database and you can
pick the database name you pick a
username and a password for now our
database name is epic name there is no
table within it and then we've chosen a
password so what we're going to do is go
over creating a table a database is
really a collection of tables and then
within the tables a table is just like a
spreadsheet like an Excel spreadsheet so
let's make this epic table and the
number of fields we're going to have
we'll just make two fields for now and
you'll hit go and that will make you get
the option to set this up so the first
field we're going to say is we'll say
name and this will be the person's name
in a year you choose the type of data
that's going to be in this case it'll be
text to leave that all blank this next
field is going to be age age is going to
be an integer and the rest will just
leave blank again and we'll come over
here that's good so now we'll just say
save hair folks to be out of field here
it'll add another field it's really easy
to hit go but yeah if you've got to this
point you're like oh shoot i really want
to add one more than you've added moral
what a lot of people will do to is have
a primary key which is a self
incrementing ID basically but this is
just a basic tutorial I just want to
show you guys how to connect and use a
database so anyway we're going to go
ahead and save this and we have now
created the table epic table and so
within this table you can see we've got
an A our name and age so we can store
um name and age data so if we go to
browse well I guess we can't browse
because there's no there's nothing in
our database yet so we need to put
something in it so let me insert so
let's just insert some data so we'll say
a name interesting name will say well we
already went over this Harrison that's
my name and then we'll do age we already
discussed this i'm ninety-nine so we'll
hit go and now we have an insert a row
so when we go to browse the database we
can see this is our database table here
we can see okay well we've got a name
Harrison age 99 so we have one entry
into our database so now let's discuss
how to connect to the database and
actually start maybe inserting and then
maybe reading from the database as well
so let's hop right into that so now back
to our PHP script what we want to do is
connect to that database so the best way
to do that is let's leave the I guess
we'll leave the header there and now
what we want to do is specify the
information to connect to it you could
type it all in here like this but it's
best just to store this in the variable
so we'll go ahead and do SQL host equals
what then we'll do SQL user equals what
and then we'll do sqo pass equals what
okay oh and make sure you put your
semicolons here so then we want to go
ahead and define these parameters here
so the host name is the IP address if
you're using your own if you've got X
amber or whatever on your computer and
apache then this will just be a local
host but otherwise you can find that
server addresses by right here is this
IP so you'll come back over to your
script and that's what good is going to
go in there in this case it's 50 60 32
30 to 27 then the username and password
is whatever you define whenever you made
it in my case it's going to be epic name
and then it's going to be at big has now
I know if somebody's going to definitely
try to connect to this with these
parameters whenever i'm done with this
video but i will be deleting all these
and this username won't exist anymore so
don't waste time anyway continuing on
that's what we're going to fill in there
and then in here with these parameters
you're just going to fill in this so
first you've got sqo underscore host
then you've got SQL underscore user and
then finally you have SQL underscore
pass so now what this is going to do is
we'll connect using these parameters and
if it can't connect it'll just exit and
it's a failed to connect to the database
otherwise it's going to say connected so
now we'll save that will run it and will
pop over here we're refresh and sure
enough we've connected to the database
now that we have you no good parameters
in here now once you've connected to the
database the next thing you need to do
is connect to the table and with that
I'm going to continue connecting to the
table in the next video as always thank
you for watching thanks for your support
your subscriptions and until next time